I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the Gigi kinomi which allows
its user to control magnetism it was
eaten by useless kid captain of the kid
pirate with it you control magnetism and
create anything you want out of metal
this includes a rampaging ball rail guns
overpowered fists and so much more a
quite attractive 22 out of 25 points in
terms of Defense you can build
positively impressive armor to protect
yourself for 20 points and for special
abilities this fruit has the potential
to make anything magnetic so you can
stick your annoying little sibling to
the wall 18 points and this route is
also incredible for everyday use as long
as there is metal around you can create
literally anything that you can imagine
instantly 24 points however that
strength also comes with a slight
weakness because in order to best use
the fruit there has to be metal nearby
so too bad if you're in the middle of a
forest for instance so we have to deduct
a repelling three points bringing its
total to a maggastic 81 points Landing
it on number two on the list for now